women with autism this is you ability to
memorize things very quickly notice
details that nobody else noticed you
know all of these things I went one a
little bit of a superwoman suddenly now
you're in this book
[Music]
welcome to divide it a real pleasure to
meet you actually
and for those of our viewers who don't
know you how would you describe yourself
so well my name is Relena
I am ethnically Filipino and German but
I was born here in the UK
my parents are Dutch I'm a stand-up
comic I work in cabaret theatre acting
and I'm also autistic so I said that's a
back story and a half in in in a few
words it fills 20 minute comedy sets
well just on that actually many people
will hear the word stogie of the free
stand-up comic and and autism and find
it quite difficult to reconcile the two
I think less so now I think more and
more in the community people are going
oh that's why I'm good at this
because we are different we you know we
see things differently we think things
differently and also I think just the
experience you have through childhood
that sets you apart slightly that makes
you slightly other I'm finding more and
more of my colleagues are either being
diagnosed or coming out so it's not
those two things together are not as
uncommon as we might have first thought
we used to associate comedians with
being depressive or generally having
some kind of mental health issue which
we feel that we sort of debunk towards
the end of the 90s but now this is
coming in in no way as a negative but
just as a oh that makes a lot of sense
[Music]
[Music]
well explain the sense behind it because
obviously there is a spectrum of
autistic of autism and there's how
functioning and unless what is it about
about autism that they you think I'll be
your autism that has contributed what is
it about the background that has set you
up for this career I think that's a
really good point yes autism is a
spectrum so we are we aren't speaking
about the entire spectrum I certainly
can't speak for the entire spectrum I
can only speak from a my really my point
of view and the way that's affected me
it certainly it certainly has always
determined the way that I think the way
that I process information the way that
I might say something that you shouldn't
say I've had a lot of good friends over
the years that that will go OK that was
funny but you know you can't say that
and in general public going ok note it
but for whatever reason you say it on
stage and everyone goes uh
she speaks the truth it's so funny and I
think that's one of the things that
comedy is comedy is about saying the
things that everybody thought but nobody
said out loud especially if you're
talking about political or social
commentary
Internet Explorer spies
anyone
when you
[Music]
but if you look
all eyes in the sky
I'm trying to popular belief people
think that people with autism don't have
a sense of humor or don't understand
humor when in quite the opposite way I
find that that especially people who
identify with having Asperger's is
actually a quite dry and wry and
incredibly witty because of the way that
they've noticed things that other people
don't or they don't take for granted
social norms that maybe the rest of the
community would see I can I can
understand why it could be incredibly
beneficial for the career on the stage I
can also imagine that it might have been
quite difficult particularly when you
were growing up and perhaps before he
died before you realizing that you're
autistic
there was no realization - I was well
into into adulthood for me although when
you get diagnosed diagnosed and part of
that process was you know I have two
children that are diagnosed is they look
at the family history because it is
understood to be a familial trait that
can be passed down and then when we
looked backwards and my family history
just went oh how did we not spot that my
computer programming mother and to be a
computer programmer in the you know in
the 60s 70s for anyone was unique but
for a small Filipino woman was unheard
of you going I think there were signs
that you know that it that it existed in
the family but growing up it's what I
find fascinating and these are the
things that I don't think you couldn't
scientifically put your finger on but if
you speak to a lot of people growing up
as children a lot of people with autism
describe feeling like an alien you just
sort of don't feel the same as everybody
else around you and they also don't feel
that you're the same it works both ways
there a number of times where the way I
would describe it is that if you were in
an emergency any kind of crisis then
each would save their own if you had a
roomful you had you know a roomful of of
what we would call neurotypicals and
teas and and autistic people they would
each save their own and that's when you
would discover how how instinctive the
feeling of different is between I'll say
communities again between because for
all the talk about being a rebellious
youth and all the rest a large part of
growing up comes for you know a lot of
the pressure comes from your pure
to conform to conform to certain norms
and if you're seeing the world in a in a
different way that possibly doesn't make
it as easy there is a lot of pressure to
conform and I think and it affects
different people growing up in different
ways because I was so clearly other and
so clearly different I went the other
way and just went I don't have to
conform I am NOT like you I don't have
to you know look at you all feeling so
pressured into drinking early or having
boyfriends and girlfriends
I need none of this but it is at the
same time very lonely you own it you own
it because if you don't own it it's
forced upon you at least in my
experience so I was very much I would
choose to stand to the side before I got
pushed to the side you said that the you
didn't that the realisation of the
autism didn't come until quite late I
mean a lot of people can get his
identified earlier tell us about that
when that happened I mean it was
actually it was a gig I believe well so
it autism was not spoken about my
childhood it was not a known thing it
wasn't really conversed about publicly
in the eighties and nineties but nor did
we have the internet nor did we have the
ability to you know spread information
the way that we do now so it was in my
it was in my 20s that I started to hear
about it and read about it and going
this brings a bellick you know this is
vibrating on the right frequency for me
you know when you hear something go oh
that feels right and I had very strong
suspicions but it was actually at the
end of a gig and it was actually a
cabaret gig so there was nothing there
was it was not in any way mentioned in
the gig we were all performing and
singing and dancing and Larkin about and
afterwards someone came up to me and in
in their various perchick way because
they they're also autistic and they work
with the NA s which is the National just
exciting they came up to me and just
went you know you're autistic you know
no hey I enjoyed that because we don't
do pleasantries I'm just you know you're
autistic anyway
oh hello to you too I hope you enjoyed
the show and and that kind of went okay
now I've had this external confirmation
from a complete stranger at the time who
had who had used his we call aid our gut
gaydar they've got a dar and a dar is
definitely a thing where you can walk
into a room and go you don't know it but
you're on the spectrum so what if what
effect did that have I mean it didn't
force you
change your personality type it just may
be that when that made me go in and look
into getting you know that made me go
and seek out diagnosis and made me go
and you know initially to the doctor to
the GP if anyone wonders the route and
just you can do it privately as well and
just say look I've always struggled with
a B and C I think it might be this and
going forward from there to find out
that it was that and from that point on
the from what I understand you started
to include some kind of that nods
towards disability and in your sense
well slowly but surely I think that when
your community when you write about
what's in your head you know you anyone
creative well you know if you're an
artist of any kind you're you're trying
to process the conversation in your head
and I have a lot of conversations going
on in my head at the same time and so
that was obviously very prominent I went
from you know just diagnosis and it's a
very strange concept because you are
autistic no matter what you're in many
you're born autistic and your artistic
for life but it's only when a medical
professional sort of Greenlight's you
that you're allowed to say that you are
and you suddenly go from being normal or
an on a on you know just a member of the
community to being special you know it's
just suddenly you're suddenly you were
the same person you were before but
suddenly you've got a label and you've
got a different parking space and it all
changes just with one doctor or a series
of doctors going tick tick tick boom
you're over here because it's a hidden
disability it's known as a Hindu spin
you can't see it's um you know obviously
there's some that you you can see it
straight away and and people will
recognize that and for some you have to
you know you have to go through a
process but for me to suddenly in one
day with one couple of pieces of
paperwork to go from being from here to
being special and you just go what so
that was a lot for me to process because
also everything that I thought did make
me special everything you know my
ability to process information my
ability to memorize things very quickly
notice details that nobody else notice
do mathematical equations in my head you
know all of these things I went well I'm
a bit of a bit of a superwoman suddenly
no you're in this book here you go
here's an entire book you know women
with autism this
you this is how you deal with
relationships this is how you deal with
with with sensory issues suddenly I
wasn't me anymore I will everything that
I had identified as really know that
okay fine I'm not like the rest of you
I'm not getting asked to prom but I've
got these skills was textbook and I'd
lost myself there was one thing that you
wrote and I think that we did I just
wanted to get your view on this you
wrote about moving from rear to artistic
career to no really real with autism and
I just wonder as we can have look at
this whole conversation in the right how
much of you is your autism compared to
for example your ethnicity compared to
your kind of the moving around when you
were younger it's tricky to unpick isn't
it it's really tricky to unpick because
I definitely identify as an Asian woman
but I don't I'm not an Asian woman with
a strong cultural connection because my
mother herself wasn't raised in the
Philippines she was raised in the US as
an American um but I still identify very
strongly with a lot of the traits that
we associate with being Asian but if you
start to look at this
there's a lot of overlap between what we
associate with the the Asian mind the
mathematics and the efficiency you know
and and the the abilities the musical
abilities for example you know the
academic abilities but then if you
switch over my father's German and we
associate that with the Germans as well
they're they're very efficient and
they're very good at you know their
economics and their math and then and
then you switch again and you go we'll
hang on a second what do we associate
with with high functioning autistic
often and often erroneously I will you
know people like Sheldon on the Big Bang
Theory don't necessarily help with that
stereotype but they're oh they're very
good at physics and they're very good at
science in the very good so all three of
those identities kind of meshed together
into into you know why aren't I am a
professor in you know at Oxford you know
I was like my daughter I was also
advanced I also was a year ahead in
school my mother was a year ahead in
school so I think all of that it it's
very tricky to separate sometimes the
autism from the Asian
the German but then my mother is also an
Asian autistic and that would be why she
was advanced at school and a physicist
and a computer programmer I think that
it
this is what I was talking about you
lose yourself for a year and go what's
me and what's the condition and then
eventually you go no no the condition is
a part of who I am the way that I have
brown hair and I have brown eyes and I
have an autistic brain and you accept it
as part of who you are
we're all very complicated Venn diagrams
oh yeah I love a Venn diagram really no
it's been an absolute pleasure talking
to you thanks for joining us on - thank
you